alimentos más caros otra consecuencia de
la pandemia a medida que las economías
se reactivan y la demanda se estabiliza
los precios de productos básicos se
disparan
de acuerdo a la onu el índice global de
precios de los alimentos alcanzó en mayo
su nivel más alto en una década
esto se produce por una demanda
creciente y una disrupción en la
disponibilidad de los productos también
se suman fenómenos climáticos que
alteran la producción de materias primas
como es el caso de brasil golpeado tanto
por una extensa sequía como por inéditas
bajas temperaturas
esta subida va de la mano con el
incremento de los precios de transportes
empresas que han apostado durante años a
la política de poco inventario están
enfrentando escasez de suministros y las
tarifas se han multiplicado hasta seis
veces según el índice de drewry en la
semana del 19 de agosto el costo de
transportes marítimos registró su
decimoctava semana seguida de incremento
de precios un 360 por ciento más en
comparación con la misma semana de 2020
una tendencia que las economías
desarrolladas se esperan revertir en
2022 pero que podría generar
consecuencias más prolongadas en países
emergentes y en desarrollo
a contramano va al mercado de la
vivienda que se ha beneficiado de la
pandemia
esto también ha provocado un alza en los
precios de 73 por ciento en el primer
trimestre de 2021 la subida más veloz
desde 2006 según la consultora
inmobiliaria británica knight frank las
tasas de interés es más bajas en los
estímulos fiscales y la capacidad de
ahorro han impulsado a los sectores de
mayores recursos a buscar casas más
amplias sobre todo ante el auge del
teletrabajo
la economía lucha por estabilizarse en
medio de una pandemia que aún no ha
terminado y con la amenaza latente de la
variante delta